[Music]
Khloe Kardashian is just now processing
Tristan Thompson's alleged cheating
scandal and a source exclusively reveals
to ET that Khloe is staying in Cleveland
to figure out her future in the wake of
it all I'm gonna figure it all out our
source says quote Khloe is very torn on
what to do with her and Tristan adding
Khloe loves him deeply he is the father
of her child but she feels betrayed and
blindsided there's a million different
emotions that are going on in my brain
despite the drama surrounding Tristan's
alleged cheating scandal Khloe's family
has rallied around her with support I've
taught my kids from day one you know
family's everything so that comes first
that same philosophy seems to be
carrying over into Chloe's legacy our
source says her main focus is figuring
out what is best for truth after the 33
year old revealed her newborn daughter's
name on social media she proudly gushed
over her baby girl writing in part our
little girl true Thompson has completely
stolen our hearts and we are overwhelmed
with love
[Music]